For much of the 20th century, we believed and were led to believe that...
...environmental sustainability and economic growth...
...or the environment and the economy were really...
...two forces pulling in opposite directions.
I think the interesting thing that we now face at the beginning of the 21st century,...
...particularly on the back of all the lessons we've learned...
...about climate change is that that really is a false dichotomy.
Economic growth, sustained economic development...
...ultimately will be threatened by environmental destruction,...
...by the risks that an unsustainable use of our natural source base...
...or indeed the impacts of economic development...
...on the atmosphere, on the hydrological cycle we'll have.
So, I think the fascinating point in time that we have reached now...
...is that sustainability becomes, in many ways, a precondition...
...for future economic development.
And that means we need to recalibrate the basic policy...
...economic and investment parameters...
...with which we look at the future economic development path.
Sustainability is now a defining and enabling condition for economic growth.
We haven't reached that point yet but I think that is the discussion...
...that is now happening in our societies, in businesses, in boardrooms.